[Music]
oh
oh god
mr stud all night
ever
[Music]
uh
this is pointless i know where i'm gonna
strike before i do it
here for a fight which one of you is my
guy
[Music]
me i wasn't expecting the tag team
but whatever i guess so who do i got
first
no no you don't get it that body and
this one
i'm the same person so
what i'm seeing double i used to be
twins
which you could probably guess the twins
had a close bond
they wanted to be closer stronger
so they installed neural oscillation
sinks and now they're
well me one person
two bodies my bodies do everything
together
[Music]
everything
but we're raising the stakes
fair
[Music]
see no problem with that so can we
get started show me what you got
[Music]
hey wait
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
and you had enough like your brother or
hungry for more
that ain't my brother oh that's me
jesus what's so hard to understand
here your winnings
[Music]
do it all don't worry there's always the
next fight
stop talking to yourself